si vous voulez me faire dire ce que je
n'ai pas envie de dire je vais quand
même le dire les alliés auraient tout ça
sont du même résultat sans la france
alors comment expliquez vous que nous
nous retrouvons tout de même à la fin
assis avec les vainqueurs nous ne sommes
pas à yalta où l'on croit en tout cas du
général de gaulle va nous faire croire
conseiller partager le monde
nous ne sommes pas à téhéran dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure nous nous sommes
invités d'une part nous avons été
vaincus d'une manière terriblement
humiliante en 1940
nous n'avons joué qu'un rôle symbolique
qu'on va dire dans cette seconde guerre
mondiale à partir de là et pourtant nous
avons non seulement une zone
d'occupation à berlin mais nous
siègeront au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu nous faisons partie des quatre
vainqueurs de la seconde guerre mondiale
il y aura des juges français au tribunal
de nuremberg
comment pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que
c'était l'île roosevelt
nous on fait ce cadeau alors bien
entendu on n'écartera pas le miracle du
général de gaulle c'est à dire sa
capacité à en tout lieu et à tout moment
à faire entendre la voix de la france ça
c'est incontestable mais on doit une
fière chandelle à churchill en réalité
parce que churchill à partir de 1944 se
projette dans cette europe d'après
guerre et il s'est bien sûr s'il y
connaissent ces américains ne connaît
bien sa mère est américaine cherchait
dissèque les américains vont pas rester
en europe
d'abord parce qu'on pense que la guerre
au japon va durer plus longtemps et on
n'a jamais vu une armée américaine
s'installer longtemps d'occupation le
précédent 1918-19 est dans tous les
esprits
ça veut dire quoi concrètement ça veut
dire que l'angleterre mme se retrouver
seul face à une puissance qui va 2000 à
la moitié du continent
nyon soviétique l'angleterre c'est
qu'elle n'est pas de taille donc
churchill va tout faire pour jouer la
carte française face à deux hommes qui
lui étaient hostiles un staline comme
nous elles n'étaient pas les amis de
gaulle mais c'est c'est quand même sur
tille et sa de gaulle lui rendra hommage
aussi c'est churchill qui pensent que la
france a de beaux restes
quelle est encore une puissance
respectable
qu'elle va se reprendre qu'elle possède
toujours son empire qu'elle a quand même
ses 40 millions d'habitants sa position
stratégique en europe occidentale avec
ce pays qui figure au rang des
vainqueurs
on va pouvoir peut-être peut-être
reconstruire une europe de l'ouest
capable de tenir tête à ce que capables
de relever ce que cherchent ils pressent
depuis longtemps être le grand défi de
l'après guerre c'est à dire une présence
soviétique au coeur de l'europe
[Musique]